schools still out we don't really know
if you were basing it just on the
evidence at the moment you'd have to say
not very well what are we trying to do
now in my opinion this is not spoken
administration policy but in my opinion
what we're trying to do there is to
train and transfer are the two key words
train up Afghan security forces police
and army to a sufficient degree where
they can take over the security
assignment for the country and then
transfer transfer one piece of Afghan
after another to the new Afghan forces
and at some point say we've done enough
it's now your problem we transfer most
of it to you and we're leaving can we
can we make that work I have to be
skeptical but that that is what I think
we're trying to do I'm skeptical for
several reasons first of all the Taliban
is that once again a major force and the
Taliban wants a whole different kind of
society than an awful lot of Afghan
isn't Lee that we want and the second
thing is the security forces that we are
training and increasing in terms of
numbers are not very reliable at this
point if they don't become more reliable
it's very difficult to transfer to them
a big city like Kandahar or Kabul and
then the other problem is regionally
their neighbors have different attitudes
about what a hat what ought to happen in
the afghanistan-pakistan wants to keep
it as a sort of vassal state of
potential use in some sort of conflict
with India so they are at the same time
that they are in some ways cooperating
with us in trying to to contain and then
eradicate if you will the Afghan Taliban
they are quietly under the table
supporting I mean the Pakistan
taliban there under the table supporting
the Afghan Taliban gets complicated but
what it means is that we have an ally in
this situation that has two strategies
they're following one is to cooperate
with us and the other is to cooperate
with the Taliban in this country that
they want to keep as a vassal that makes
it very very difficult to have a
political future that looks manageable
right now at the moment the central
government if you will the national
government of Afghanistan controls the
capital and a few regions around it and
that's it the rest of the country is
either in warlord control or Taliban
control or in nobody's control now we
are also I think are essentially
admitting that we cannot pacify the
whole country we can't even transfer the
whole country we're essentially saying
that to the Afghan government will train
up troops and we'll put them in huge
population areas the rest of the country
the mountainous areas and so on that's
more than we can handle and maybe it's
more than you can handle so at best if
we were to be able to pull this off
train and transfer and win over some
recruits from the Taliban by giving them
a share of the government the best
you're going to have is a very disturbed
hard to manage mountainous country that
is potentially an affliction from time
to time to its neighbors the one thing
that we have to try and make sure it
doesn't happen is that international
terrorist groups like al-qaeda can use
it again as a base for training for
strategy for planning major events like
911 if we can do that with whatever
government is there by time we're ready
to leave and with the security forces
Afghan security forces that are in place
that's about the best that I think we
can expect
you